let's head to South London where we're
going to be joined by The Shadow
Chancellor of the Duchy of Lancaster
Labour's Rachel Reeves Missouri's very
good morning to you good morning nail um
I wonder if we might start with a
question that that will be weighing very
heavily or on the minds of many people
today whether or not pupils should be
returning to schools in England on the
1st of June for that to happen what does
the Labour Party need to see change well
we must remember that schools have been
open during the course of this pandemic
all the schools in my constituency in
Leeds Western around the country have
been open for the children of key
workers and for the most vulnerable
children Labour Party and all of us want
to see more children attending school
anybody who's attempted home schooling
or helping children with their lessons
at home know how hard that is and know
that for the best possible education we
want to see our children in the
classroom but to do that in a safe way
two things need to happen first of all
the government need to work with parents
teachers and their unions so ensure that
the new plans have the competence of
everybody so that parents feel confident
to send their children to school but
also we need more transparency from
government the Prime Minister said last
Sunday that all the decisions that are
going to be made about easing lockdown
will be based on the science and here we
are a week later and those details have
not been published and that is a cause
for concern and adds to the anxiety
amongst teachers and teaching staff and
parents about the safety in the BMA the
British Medical Association are also
urging caution so instead of dialing up
the rhetoric we want government to work
with teachers parents and the teaching
unions to get this right I wonder if we
might return to transparency in a moment
I know that you've written a letter to
another guest in the program this
morning Michael Gove and you may we'll
want to do some of those questions on
the air but in terms of the balancing
act that has to be carried out right now
everyone seems to be aware of the fact
that the longer that children are out of
school the greater the negative effects
on them this is a difficult balancing
act isn't it
it is a difficult balancing act and
schools the pose particular problems
because social distancing particularly
for young children anybody who's got
young children knows that keeping poor
and five-year-olds of apart from each
other and sticking by the rules is
really really tough and also because
although in most workplaces wearing
personal protective equipment can help
reduce the spread of the virus again
that's really tricky in schools but for
teachers and particularly young people
to to wear face masks for example is
probably not appropriate in most school
settings and so there are a unique set
of challenges in schools but it is
really important the the education of
our young people but also for their
mental health and well-being that they
are back to school as soon as it is safe
to do so and to do that we need to work
together government need to work with
teachers and parents as I say but also
government need to put in place some of
the measures to improve confidence and
that includes the test trace and isolate
strategy the government abandoned that
back in the middle of March that was a
mistake because the countries that have
most successfully tackled the virus have
had extensive systems of test trace and
isolate and the governor now said they
want to bring that back by midnight
well it is now the 17th of May the
government have contracted out the
recruitment of people to that to the
private firm
Serco they've only recruited one in ten
of the people that the government say
that they need many experts say you need
a lot more people than the 18,000 the
government's are looking for the app
that the government of trialing in the
Isle of Wight seems to have a number of
problems including not working with
older versions of smartphones we need
that test trace and isolate a strategy
in place so that we can spot and any
spikes in the virus in particular parts
of the country and put in place measures
to isolate people who have come into
contact with those who have banned to
test positive and it misery sorry to
interrupt but just be absolutely clear
is it the Labour Party's position that
children shouldn't be going back to
schools until the contract tracing
system it's so the contact tracing
system is up and running
isn't just about schools this is about
wider issues around easing some of the
lockdown restrictions but the anxiety
that teachers and parents face I think
would be a lot less if we had that test
tres an isolate strategy in place the
government said okay but be very
specific we would be given we are
talking about schools is it the Labor
Party's position that the school should
not be open until contract contact
tracing is up and running well we want
that to be up and running to ease the
whole range of the lockdown restrictions
but specifically on schools we want
government to work with the teachers and
parents and teaching unions to give them
confidence and to publish the science
upon which the decision is being made to
reopen schools but the government have
committed to have contact tracing in
place by the middle of May that isn't
yet the case we've got two more weeks
before schools are set to increase the
numbers of children coming in the
government I've got two weeks to put in
place that test and trace to publish the
science and work with teachers other
staff at schools and parents to give
them confidence we're not in that place
yet the government have got a lot more
work to do to give that confidence that
it will be safe to have more children
coming into school in two weeks time
should we though expect parents of
children within the state sector to be
sending their kids back when large parts
of the independent sector have already
announced their schools will remaining
closed for the until after the summer
well I would like to have more children
at school I think all of us um want that
whether children are at private schools
or state schools with the vast vast
majority of children attend state
schools and that is where the government
has the most authority but I would like
to see schools in the state sector and
in the independent sector open but my
biggest concerns are about the most
disadvantaged children and they are in
the state sector and many of the most
vulnerable children have not been
attending a school some of them have
become almost invisible over the last
few weeks for many children school is
the safest place for them to be and that
is an additional reason why we would
like to have more children attending
school and that's why it's
so important that instead of dialing up
the rhetoric the government actually
will start working with teachers and
other staff at schools and with parents
to build that confidence and that is the
best way to get people back into schools
but to do it in a safe way because the
last thing anyone wants to see is a
second spike in the virus a spike in the
virus at schools and that means working
together to make sure it is as safe as
it possibly can be the government has
still got two weeks to get this right
but haven't approached it in the right
way so far please government use the
next two weeks to get this right to
enable more children to attend schools
but to do it in a way that builds
confidence and is as safe as possible at
mysteries I wonder if we can talk
briefly about brexit and you will have
seen in the papers this morning any
number of reports about the the state or
the state of the negotiations a parlous
state of negotiations increased
preparations for exiting in WTO terms
what is the Labor Party's position this
morning you know 22900 on whether or not
the United Kingdom should avoid at all
costs leaving without a deal we
absolutely did not want to leave the
European Union with a deal we have
already left this is about our future
trading relationship we've got a
transition period until the end of year
that is enshrined in in statute in in
British law we want to ensure that there
is as good a deal as possible by the end
of this year the last thing it strikes
me that one thing that you haven't
mentioned though is an extension to the
transition period well the government
have enshrined in law that we the
transition period comes to an end at the
end of this year the government are
still saying and you'll have Michael
Gove on the program later the government
are still saying that that is and that
that is possible that they have no
intention of seeking an extension I
would say to the government the most
important thing is that we get a good
deal not ever any deal but the best deal
that we can have and the last thing our
country and our economy need at the
moment is a further shock that could put
jobs and livelihoods at risk so don't
rush this all of the attention of
government at the moment is on
fighting the coronavirus that is the
right thing don't rush it but make the
time that is needed but at the moment
government is saying that we can still
do this by the end of the year we need
to hold them to account
so getting not just any deal but the
best deal we can by the end of this year
what mysteries I mean you're telling
you're telling the government not to
rush things you're suggesting that the
most important thing is to get a good
deal I don't understand why the labor
parties and screaming from the rooftops
then for an extension to the transition
period well we want government to focus
wholly at the moment on tackling the
coronavirus but the government's are
still saying that they can get that deal
by the end of this year you'll remember
at the election deal that the government
said that they had an oven-ready deal
and that this would be the simplest deal
to negotiate the government is still
saying that is the case we're saying
that they mustn't rush this and if that
they are not going to a security we
mustn't crash out without a deal so that
means taking the time that is necessary
but it's up to government to show they
can deliver the promises that they've
made to the British people and that is
getting a good deal and a good deal by
the end of this year and if they are not
in a position to do that they need to
come back and explain a timetable Rachel
it's really good to see this morning
thanks for being on the show do trust
that you and yours are very well indeed